just a a piece of information before we
i read the chairman script for next
tuesday we are meeting
but we're not going to be starting until
10 30.
and the reason for that is the senate of
course is doing their nine o'clock
hearing of our bills
and
there there's a real conflict there and
folks uh both parties are probably
wanting to testify
and that makes it very difficult when
you're exacting on this side of the
ledger too so uh we're going to be
starting at 10 30. we only have a few
bills to exact that day so it should go
quickly and
most likely it should be out by noon ish
12 30 that day so with that i'm going to
go ahead and read the chairman script
and then we'll have a little bit more
discussion in some of the
scheduling
as chair of the house education
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of tobit 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a uh executive
session which we're we're going to be
exacting uh bills that have been
previously heard
it is a public meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen perpetually to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the calendar
house calendar and through the
electronic calendar in the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
or email hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that is
assisting us today jennifer iv is our
committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll paul voter
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law thank you
shaw
representative you're in the committee
room president home here in the
committee room representative
representative of uh lancast here in the
city room
representative
here in the house with eight colleagues
here in the committee room
representative
here home alone in salisbury all by
myself oh you know what i tried to
volunteer represented ford
here alone in my office in chester
representative lyon here in the
committee room representative
you're in the committee room president
milor
kieran contour
in my office alone representative
here
representative shaw here in the
committee room president cornell
here but my husband is also home not
feeling well today
[Music]
uh here in sunapee uh with my rescue dog
raven who may bark
i'm here in concord alone in my home
here in bedford uh in my basement studio
here i am home alone in jaffrey new
hampshire
here in santa clara new hampshire with
my wife and my dog who definitely will
bark
represent his class
i'm here in the llb
and representative
uh representative allard is getting his
uh coveted shot and i hope he has a good
experience
and he'll be here shortly okay
so we're good reps in the shop yes thank
you president thank you very much
uh just a brief note uh for those that
tuned in and listened to the meeting we
had yesterday dealing with the higher
uh study that we have going on
it was a very interesting meeting
uh it indicates that there's still a lot
a lot of work for us to do and we have
one more session available
and that's on friday so i i i'm
pretty much guaranteeing that we're
going on friday we're going to have
barbara brittenham uh she's very
involved with accreditation of higher
education institutions
uh and she's done a lot of work with all
those in the
new england region the post secondary
schools she'll be working with us on
that following that there will be a real
work session on our behalf
trying to compile some uh facts and
information if we want to ship off to uh
division two i expect that meeting to go
much beyond probably 12 o'clock it's
scheduled to go from 10 to 12 but due to
the fact we need to get that
uh uh identified in the report and do it
as best we can i suspect it will go
maybe as we discussed yesterday in that
subcommittee
i i
i indicated we could go at least
probably to two o'clock and i saw
representative miller shake and said yes
that's probably so
um this is a huge topic i was very
impressed yesterday
with the information received from
plymouth state from the
community college system from uh
uh chancellor heward
and from the higher education uh system
from
um
uh catherine provencher and from the
chair of the university system joe moran
is also
ceo for the
albany international corporation which
is a huge huge business
so
with that
we will be having a little longer
meeting than uh folks may have
expected or seen in the past
so with that i'd like to get into
today's um
executive sessions i will be calling
this short around two o'clock today
uh if we have to even go that long but
we have the five bills i believe set up
for today i have my second povid shot i
understand the second shot is something
you should look forward to
um so
it's
pretty hard i guess
i'll try to forget it and get on with
what we're doing here today uh the first
bill which we have is cacr
that is a bill that deals with the quote
blaine amendment so with that um i would
love to um represent a mop for a
promotion
thank you miss chair i would simply like
to move uh uh to pass on this cacr 3.
thank you is there a second
representative i would like to second
thank you uh representative would you
like to speak to your motion
uh sure mr very briefly uh this is
simply
to remove one line from our uh present
constitution the so-called blaine
amendment
the recent supreme court case of
espinosa versus montana
pretty much supersedes and relegates
that in terms of it being cited in any
future legal action and again i just
would say it's a 19th century relic uh
some of us see it as a relic of the
more intolerant time and it's uh time to
look at it and and we think remove it
thank you
it's a ditto over there
uh further discussion from the committee
at this time
and uh represent cordelia did you have
your hand up yes uh thank you mr
chairman
uh
i think there are two reasons
that this uh
amendment or no aid amendment needs to
be removed from
uh our constitution i believe it's
sustained
on our historic constitution
um
first um as representative mentioned
the espinosa decision
clearly
finds
language such as this in state
constitutions
representative lag can you ask
representative cordelia to move closer
we got to move to mike thanks you got it
thanks glenn thank you
um
the uh
the blaine amendment or no eight
amendments in the state constitutions
um
really uh have uh been
decided as unconstitutional by the
espinoza versus montana department of
revenue case
as we have heard uh the
uh
the language
uh is
unconstitutional uh being the first
reason it should be removed
uh the second reason is that it is
as representative said
a relic of anti-religious bigotry
of the uh
19th century and early 20th century
and it went up into the 1920s
um there was a
a reinvigoration of the anti-religious
and anti-jewish and anti-catholic school
movement uh
in the 1920s both in oregon and in maine
the ku klux klan was very active in
maine in the 1920s uh trying to
prevent the spread of
catholic schools in particular
in oregon
there was a law passed
that
all students all
uh children had to be taught
by public school teachers
uh this was also actively uh supported
by the ku klux klan out there as a means
of
getting rid of catholic schools
that had sprung up
as a result of
catholic migration from ireland and
other countries in europe
supreme court uh
or the case went to the supreme court uh
because of the challenges of a military
school
and a um
an orphanage that taught students
there were exceptions in the law but
these schools were concerned about their
ability to continue
in operation
and the case went all the way to the
supreme court it became known as the uh
pierce the governor of oregon versus the
society of sisters
and i want to quote one
i think very important a couple of
sentences from that uh
court opinion
the fundamental theory of liberty upon
which all governments in this union
repose
excludes any general power of the state
to standardize its children
by forcing them to accept instruction
from public
public teachers only
the child is not the mere creature of
the state
those who nurture him and direct his
destiny have the right
coupled with the high duty to recognize
and prepare him for additional
obligations
i think that that
then
also comes into play with recent
court decisions u.s supreme court
decisions
lutheran and zealman
not to mention the espinoza case
in which
it has been found that
these
types of scholarship programs or
education programs where the money goes
to the parent to find the best education
opportunities for their child they're
not mere creatures of the state the
funds are controlled by the parent to
find the best educational opportunities
for their
child and i think that very much played
into the
uh
espinosa decision that we have talked
about
and
the
court struck down the oregon
the montana blaine amendment which is
very similar to our uh blaine amendment
uh
and so
i think for both reasons the
unconstitutionality
and the history of religious bigotry
that the blaine amendment was uh based
upon
are the two primary reasons that uh this
relic needs to be uh removed as a stain
on our constitution
thank you mr chairman very much
representative
represented wood talk did you have your
hand up earlier
i saw it thank you thank you
representative i did actually um you
know and i appreciate the comments by uh
president of cordelli as the prime
sponsor of this bill i do recall that i
think the vote was 46 to 236 against on
input from the public but beyond that i
was looking at the amended the amended
version
uh the analysis of the amended verizon
the last page of the
print out on my computer
talks about if the amendment is adopted
under the voter's guide
and it says this prohibition
will be removed and money raised by
taxation
should be granted or applied to the use
of school for religious sect or
determination
so this if i understand this i
understand the plain amendment i
understand the
the that our constitution the new
hampshire constitution as well are old
uh and been around for a long time it
takes a
humongous amount of work to change them
uh and not often change but this is a
radical change uh it's not just a blaine
amendment change this is saying that the
money we raise locally to pay for local
public education can now be forwarded
through this change in the literature to
uh private religious schools
i have no problem private religious
schools uh at all in fact they put out
some terrific uh youngsters that being
said i do have a
problem using public education money to
do that so i i understand where
representative cornell is coming from
the this is not just a simple caac
offering this is embedded in a lot more
of the overview of the uh
education act of the the fair school act
of trying to do the voucher act this is
this is just a small piece we're taking
a small piece here it's a much bigger
picture
so i think trying to ruse this into one
little one little line change is really
just generous
and i will be voting no thank you thank
you very much uh ribs on tanner then
represent mylar
trying to get un unmuted there i go
um thank you and i just i just want to
say
that um everything i i follow up
everything that that representative
woodcock just just said
um the issue is not religious education
religious schools
the question is public funding and and
taxpayer money and um
you know in our constitution in 1784
well before there was discrimination
against catholics uh and irish people
coming into the united states
our founding fathers
wisely put in just as they did in the
u.s constitution
that the united states should not be
a religious state
it should be there should be a
separation
of religion and government and that it
didn't in any way mean that you couldn't
go to religious schools
or have religious schools or
go have any religious
services that you wanted to or belong to
any it just meant that public funds
particularly excuse me particularly for
education
should not go
for religious training so um just want
to make that point thank you
thank you um
representative miler
thank you mr chair
uh you know this this is as
representative woodcock has said this is
just part of a grand plan
to try to get funds to uh religious
schools and this is unfortunate we've
heard this blane argument odd infinitum
here
what we have to realize is that the
blane amendment came into our
constitution in the mid 1800s
the issue of the separation of church
and state was from the beginning of this
country's founding
and what this does it basically is
contrary to the basic tenets of our
nation as it relates to make sure that
there's a separation between church and
state
this bill goes way beyond what is
necessary
frankly nobody is going to argue the
issue though there should not be uh
religious discrimination here whatever
the blane blame uh senator blaine's uh
motion was
it's there
but the fine but the the basic tenets of
this country
is based upon the separation of church
and state and this runs contrary to that
tenet
and i'll be voting now on this big time
thank you
uh
the comments
cordelli should you be acting as chair
when you're the sponsor of the bill
um the uh
the uh chairman had to step out to take
a phone call he'll be back shortly
calling on people to speak at this point
okay thank you
representative mullen
thank you representative cordelli um i i
i have a i have just a couple of things
to say first of all um with regards to
this being uh a discriminatory bill
against the irish i would like to on
this the 18th of march i might add uh
comment on the fact that
uh my grandparents were in fact irish
immigrants to this country and
where i am sitting in my basement is 2.2
miles from the parochial school that i
attended as a child
um
i can tell you that i heard many stories
growing up about
no irish need apply
but not once did i hear a complaint
coming from my grandparents nor my
parents after them about having to pay
for parochial education
because they felt it was part of their
religious expression and therefore a
responsibility of our family
also you know public education came
before the establishment of parochial
schools parochial schools came about as
a result of catholics wanting to
separate themselves from a school system
that they felt had become protestantized
and um
i i i just think that referring to the
separation of church and state as a
relic
does not represent the viewpoints of the
constituents that i have heard from
in great number that are exceptionally
concerned over us using public monies
for
religious purposes
and uh because of that i will be voting
against this
thank you thank you very much
representative either further
any further discussion
yes represent cordelia thank you um
on the subject of
separation of church and state
i wish someone would point out that
praise to me in the constitution
it's not
there um let me quote from the majority
opinion in the trinity lutheran
supreme court case
denying the generally available benefits
solely on the account of religious
identity
and poses a penalty on the pre-exercised
religion
the exclusion of trinity lutheran from a
public benefit for which is otherwise
qualified solely because it is a church
is odious
odious to our constitution
and cannot stand
we know
the ruling
in the espinoza case
which basically says that to
try and
use this
amendment
as a reason
to exclude
funds to go to a religious school
if those funds can be used
to send children to a private school
it's unconstitutional it's a violation
as per the espionage decision it's a
violation of the establishment clause
of our constitution
simple as that
it's an invalid reason to
argue against this constitutional
amendment uh let me quote from justice
salido nbsp news in the espinoza case
the program helped parents of modest
means do what more affluent parents can
do
send their children to a school of their
choice
that's what this
this
issue is about and the reason to exclude
this we've had
supreme court justices testify
uh
and a right
that
when there is a parental choice involved
of what school what services what
educational options are being used
then there is no violation
of
our constitution
state constitution or
um
it's a parental choice
it's we're not compelling
any
funding
for a particular
religion or a religious organization
um
i used to live in connecticut
[Music]
taxpayers in connecticut used to pay
their taxes to the congregational church
you know if you want to talk about
separation in church
you know you can talk about you know not
paying your municipal taxes to uh to a
church
but in terms of allowing
parents see and i'll i'll
take this one step further public funds
what are tough public funds we talk
about public funds
there's no such thing as public funds
it's taxpayer money
that's what public funds are so why not
let parents use some of their taxpayer
money that they've sent to the
government to find the best education
option for their children
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much a representative
uh yeah i i thank you mr chairman just
as a point of clarification i have a
question regarding um
the the amendment in and of itself so
when we talk about funds being used i
guess representative cordelia i'll
address my question to you when we talk
about funds being used for religious
schools are we talking
you're saying that these funds could be
used at any religious school correct
uh
regardless of whether or not it was a
jewish community center a buddhist
school uh
a
christian school an islamic school uh
whatever the religious aspect is
in the
school choice
or
even trinity lutheran wasn't a school of
choice issues but in school choice
legislation where there is a choice of
what school what services the parents
want to use um that scholarship or
savings account money for
um yes it can be used for a variety of
purposes so it could be used for a
catholic school a jewish school
or
any kind of
educational services depending on what
the legislation says
could i have a follow-up mr chair
so um
is there
would there ever be a chance where a
religious school
so a school where students were in
attendance and parents were choosing to
send their children there uh was denied
money through the scholarship fund
has there been an instance of that is
is that a possibility is that is that
something that could happen or has it
happened in
other places
well in the espinoza case um yes the
department of revenue said you cannot
send your children
to um a in this that case uh mrs
espinoza wanted to send her or was
sending her children to um a christian
school and the department of revenue
said no you can't because we haven't
blamed him
i'm familiar with the case i'm just
wondering if you envision
it being um
open-ended enough that any established
religious school would be guaranteed of
getting uh
funds or if it had they had to go
through an approval process i don't
think that um there's a guarantee in
there i think it depends on the
legislation that you're looking at if
you're looking at a school choice
um
piece of legislation and in this case we
had 1820 or now 130s it says approved
schools
so they are approved by
the department of education
thank you
yeah i'd like to add in a little bit
later on today we're going to be taking
up
ab 282 which is dealing with the tuition
program that we have
for those school districts which don't
have particular traits in their in their
organizational structure but one of the
requirements
is that they must be in compliance with
the provisions of rsa 193 equal
b
and sections a and b within
uh which are those approval standards
that we're requiring so this is why uh
uh it's you'll see most of our language
saying private schools
rather than sectarian or non-sector
the effort here is to go strictly
private but you have to meet the
approval standards which are
applicable to that particular
organizational structure as set up by
department of education
representative tanner you have your hand
up
yes thank you mr chair
um i
there is
is there still
a court case pending on this very issue
in new hampshire and if so
should we
stick a constitutional amendment on the
ballot to interfere with the court case
before it's actually settled
if you're if you're directing that
question towards myself
i don't think that you know we should be
i'm not too concerned about that i'm i'm
looking at this there's always there's
always going to be some litigation
as there may be in regard even to 282 uh
wanting to send their students but this
the legislation that we have stipulates
and that's what we have to work off of
is that you must be in compliance with
193e
um
so just just a question is the court
case still pending
i i thought i heard what in testimony he
had earlier yes it is and they're hoping
that through this legislation
we may be able to you know stop that
dedication and stop these awful costs
that folks are
having to approve including the school
districts and the the person bringing
that litigation forward
so so this is an attempt
to put something in front of the court
before the court actually settles it
based on the constitution is that
correct i think that if you're looking
at the poll we're talking about cacr 3
that was
not developed as consultant it was
developed as a result of the several
court cases trinity lutheran which uh of
missouri has since developed based upon
espinosa out in montana where the report
has come down our highest sports come
down and said it's
unconstitutional
to uh
to you know to have these plain
amendments within constitutions they've
got to be eliminated i um mr chair i
my understanding is that both those
cases were fairly narrow in their
decision at the supreme court
and that
the court case in new hampshire would be
important
to
still define
what exactly
the supreme court
comes down on i think some of those uh
statements were made in
in um by justices and dissent
uh or in
in
you know
as part of the case but uh the case
itself in both espinoza
and uh the lutheran trinity lutheran
were fairly narrowly decided
all right well i'll just put it i'm not
an attorney but i was at a meeting last
night we got off 11 o'clock and
basically we had one report from one
attorney in laconia we had another one
from folks down to hanover and they're
both opposite you know
uh reports so
i guess you can get an attorney to say
what you want them to say if
you're paying the dollar for it uh
represent cordelli you have uh
thank you
[Music]
this constitutional amendment was
submitted
not because of any court case
um strictly because
i believe it's a stain on our
uh constitution because of its history
the espinosa case
basically has said
has ruled that
you know if you're using this as a basis
to exclude religious schools from a
program is unconstitutional
i don't think that
um
the margin of supreme court case
uh should be viewed as a reason to
exclude supreme court
uh or disregard supreme court cases i've
never heard that argument before whether
a case is truly a lutheran case
so should we
exclude that because it was not
unanimous i don't understand that
argument
the supreme court is the supreme court
um the uh
the limitation that i think you're
referring to
will be works best when we get to a
later bill today um but
as we heard in the testimony from the
attorney in that case
they believe that
based on the espionage
ruling
that our statute
is unconstitutional that excludes
religious schools from the town tuition
program
so i i don't think
that
supreme court case has anything to do
with this constitutional amendment
the constitutionalist amendment is being
offered because it is a relic of
anti-religious bigotry
and it's been decided by the supreme
court that it's unconstitutional
and we talked the other day about um
court cases in the future and costs to
the state well by leaving this in
the constitution is just going to invite
someone else
to
challenge some uh future legislation or
some existing legislation
and we're going to come up with the same
arguments and we're going to
we're going to come down to the same
facts
that the u.s supreme court in the
espinosa case said that if you exclude
religious schools
uh it's unconstitutional so you're going
to have all sorts of court cases and
possibly in the future and the same
outcome and the costs are going to be an
issue
as we brought up the other day
represent like this you have your hand
up
yes thank you
um apparently
there have been through time many
schools teaching separation of church
and state separation of church and state
i hear it all the time there is no such
thing
in fact that would have been unheard of
by the people who founded our country
it specifically says childhood shall not
establish a particular
set or set of beliefs because most of
the people coming to our country early
on were coming to pursue religious
freedom so that they could
worship as they wanted to
so this whole idea of separation of
church and state is historically
inaccurate
and it is in our constitution and
allowing
parents to choose a particular school
that happens to be religious and having
money that's allowed to go to other
private schools and not go to a
religious schools is very much against
what our founders intended and very
forget original constitution thank you
uh yeah briefly uh mr chair uh to follow
up on representatives comment
uh and to go back to uh i think
representative tanner alluded to the
1784 constitution uh
folks are continually conflating the
actual intent and the wording of the
constitution
it simply said we will have no state
church it does not say that the state
and various
secular or non-secular
organizations cannot work together
along those lines on the micro level i i
was involved with running start um
and bishop brady is a catholic school
here in concord that had a partnership
with nhti where
small amounts of money and
and stuff were exchanged so we we have
here in concord uh a state institution
nhci partnering with a a catholic school
bishop brady already that's on a micro
level
uh and i finally just want to point out
that
this
uh
church and state issue is is
something that folks who want to protect
a monopolistic uh establishment site
it's kind of peculiar to america uh
canada freely supports uh religious
schools uh
all over west my relatives in denmark
where
money freely goes to religious schools
so
i think it's time for us to to get out
of the 18th and 19th century and to
get into the 21st century and get with
the latest supreme court decision as
well
thank you very much uh
representative
uh thank you mr chair
and back to the bigotry part of it in
boston
they were clearly funding religious
schools in boston
until
irish and italians started moving in
and they said well you're funding those
those schools why don't you fund hours
and that's when boston chains
and massachusetts changed their law
against giving money to religious
schools so it was clearly
at the time
anti-catholic anti-italian anti-irish
so we have always done it most schools
even in new hampshire and new england a
lot of the schools of small towns
were held in the local churches it was
the biggest building in town where you
can have the church have schools so
this whole bit about religious schools
it started with
catholics coming here that was it period
thank you thank you very much uh
not seeing our hands up
clerk uh will you please call the roll
yes this is bob pass on cacr career
representative
yes
representative howard uh representative
yes representative moffitt yes
representative
yes
representative andres yes
representative ford yes
president leon yes
representative saudi yes representative
miller
no
for example
representative shaw yes
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison oh
president mullen no
senate way
nope
representative
um
will it be a minority report
yes there will i'll i'll be writing that
and representative
uh you gotta
that's our bill being on the private
school commission program
what number again
282 um
so
okay uh representative cordelli you have
a motion on that we do have an amendment
correct yes i would like to move
uh ought to pass on house bill 282
relative to a private school that is
approved as a tuition program and offer
amendment
0 616
h
uh you
so we have a
motion made to cast off the past with
amendment 0 6 1 6 h that was made
[Music]
your motion
uh thank you mr chairman
uh yes i would like to uh speak to uh
my motion
um i'll start off with the uh amendment
um which basically uh
some language
and also
puts into
the legislation
the practice is now being followed in
several
towns that have school tuition programs
um which is uh on mars
through 12 of the amendment
which basically
states that the
school
may
contract with multiple schools
to choose
the school from
the
approved tuition program
schools
that
is the current practice
in
point
today
it is their practice in uh
in goshen
um
where they even have
school fairs
to uh allow the
tuition
contracted schools
to present their
information to parents
and uh you know i've got a policy here
from uh goshen that
goes through this
um
and so
i'll quote from the uh language here
this ocean school board does not select
choice schools
any new hampshire public school would be
a choice option as long as the school
district of police led to a contract
with the goshen district
so that is clearly the
way things operate in
districts
he basis for this
is to
strike
the
language
from
current
statute that
applies to only
non-sectarian
private schools being allowed
as a
town tuition
school
and i'll point out that uh back in 2016
uh there was house bill 1637
offered by representative bone
um that was vetoed by governor hassan
and her specific reason
in the veto message was that it was a
violation of our constitution's blame
amendment but we now know
that that
reason for vetoing the program is
unconstitutional based on the espionage
decision
uh
so um
i think uh i think i'll leave it there
at this point
questions as we go as a presentation
reverend cordelie um glenn could you go
to la i'm on the amendment could you go
to line two please for me line three
you there glenn
okay so on line three it says
on line three it says
if there is no public school for the
child's grade in the district so
specifically this bill
is only if there's no public school
grade in the district is that accurate
okay and on line eight
you you have eliminated the school board
may decide on line six
but on line eight it says the school
district so i don't know who that is
the school district
down the line on line eight it doesn't
identify who actually is doing the
voting then because before it was always
the school board but that's taken out
i think you can
uh infer that the school district
is represented by the
school board
and they are the ones that do the
contract
follow up mr cheer i would i wouldn't do
that at all as small schools with the
principal
uh often negotiates or talks to other
schools and other programs so and we've
had other other situations all over the
place where this the principal that
makes the decision but this is not clear
this is just a school district who that
may be
the school secretary and moderator i
think i think that's not clear since you
specifically took the school board out
of the picture in in line
i i'd like to six
to that um
you're looking at the amended language
which modifies a small part of the
tuition program
and if you look in the original bill in
a different section section
seven
it says be a school approved and
contracted by a local public school
board to provide students with the
opportunity for an adequate education
and that reference references back to
the rsa
which has all those subjects and
criteria that are for substantive
education adequate education
so it does require the school to be
approved by the school board
you mean the
when you just the clarification
represent lead i'm not talking about the
school specifically that the youngster
is going to i'm talking about who has
the authority to send it to them as of
line eight on the amendment
i'm not suggesting it's not an approved
school that's perfectly fine
actually the bill makes sense but i i
don't understand who the school district
is
in terms of that assignment that's all
you know a smaller school that that
often the the uh someone in charge of
special ed or someone in charge of uh
bilingual or whoever happens to be will
say that's the way we're going to go i
used to you took school board out is
this is the sending group that's all
it's just i think that's an error
because we can't clarify the school
district is but i understand though
thank you representative
thank you
mr chairman yeah i like to clarify that
because
the school district are the voters in
the town and they approve the budget the
school board submits the budget the
school board says and we want to send x
number of school students to this school
it's in the budget
and this was one of my arguments when i
first brought up the croydon bill
so yes the school board to improve but
the school district
meaning the voters in that district have
to approve the budget
and in that budget it will state that
just like any other budget
thank you
the representative line the school the
school the school budget and it doesn't
tell and the voters did not tell
the school who to assign where it does
not give authority for that it doesn't
identify student exporting this school
that school where a future may came up
during the school year representative
bowen if you have a youngster in that
school and make that placement that's
not the school voters
so it goes doesn't doesn't identify who
makes the decision that's all it
identified before the board and and this
amendment takes it out
that girls are what i think brexit
if you look at lines 25 through 30
and the bill has
clearly states
who has to
tanner
thank you mr chair for recognize me um
i'm going to just read from our
constitution again
um
in
article 6
it says but no person shall be compelled
to pay towards the support of the
schools
of any sect or denomination
and just before that particular line
it talks about how religious
societies have the right to elect their
own teachers
and contracting with them for the
support of maintenance of schools or
both
so
this was the this was in
uh well before we had discrimination
against catholics
that keeps coming up with the blaine
amendment
and it was a it was a direct
article of our constitution
that's one thing i'd like to bring up
the second thing i'd like to bring up is
that this particular
bill
addresses the particular
rsa
that is being taken to court i mean we
are
with the cacr
i was uh alluding to the fact that we're
interfering with court decisions and and
court proceedings with this bill
we're actually taking
the bill the rsa
that parents are taking to court and is
presently under litigation
to change this particular language in
this particular bill
and we're voting on to change it here
we're
i i don't understand how
we feel it's uh prudent
or
the right thing to do to interfere with
litigation the other
types of um
judicial review
in espinosa and trinity lutheran were
very narrow and they dealt with money
that was not directly from taxpayers
this money in this bill where
a school board
a publicly elected school board using
public funding raised through taxation
in the town as well as state money that
comes down with adequacy and federal
funds
is sending it as you're you're saying
can send it to a religious school
i think it violates our constitution and
i think it would violate the u.s
constitution when it came down to
this particular narrow question thank
you
thank you representative representative
ellison
uh thank you mr chair a question to you
i guess
uh
i have questions about i don't have the
amendment in front of me unfortunately
but lines 27 28 in the original bill
uh if they talk about complying with
statutes and regulations relating to
agency approval such as health fire
safety and sanitation uh i'm happy to
raise my questions about that when we
get to the the bill itself or
is part of this discussion about the
amendment
suppose she references
law
okay so i i am assuming my question
at this point is in order
well i would assume that right now that
i we're looking at the amendment yes
that that crazy allergy there okay thank
you very much thank you
uh
it talks there and this is line 27 and
28 of the original
about
statutes and regulations such as health
fire safety and sanitation
which i assume would mean that a school
in school that was identified by a
school board as being a place to put
students
would
qualify under those particular
requirements
is there a similar
requirement intent
that the schools that might be approved
would also
not discriminate against anyone
according to sexual orientation
the of course the lines you're speaking
to right now you're talking about lines
27 and 28.
those that that language is currently in
law this was passed when we set up the
school tuition program several years
back
and that was set up just to ensure that
the schools melt the net the codes and
the education rules set up for those
particular three categories that are
also that's also implicitly in law
so
now you're jumping to another topic of
discrimination which this bill doesn't
speak to it speaks to
uh changing non-sectarian and private
and it also uh would be language which
you'll see on lines 29 and 30 and then
with the amendment that is what this
bill speaks to
follow up mr chairman
yes
uh then my question would be under the
amendment and the
underlying bill
would school districts be allowed to
contract with an organizational school
which discriminates against students
based on sexual orientation
school districts have to follow law and
they also have to uh make that decision
because this is made not by the state
board of education it's made by the
local board of education when they're
dealing with these contracts so
when when uh
when those
local school board members take their
oath
when they do that they also at that time
are taking a hold to
follow all the laws rules of our state
thank you
next next question rex i like this
um
i just wanted to say that even with the
narrow
if you're just looking at the narrow
interpretation of um espinoza versus
montana
this falls into that narrow
interpretation
where there is choice
town is choosing amongst private
and uh
neighboring public schools and excluding
religious schools
and that is
specifically what
the supreme court was ruling against
if there is a choice
and that choice includes other private
schools it must it cannot
exclude religious schools because that
goes against the establishment thank you
representative
thank you mr uh it's come up a couple of
a couple times today that there are some
court cases pending and that we need to
be uh aware
or even perhaps defer to these uh court
cases that are pending and i just want
to say the judicial process and the
legislative processes are totally
separate and that should not impact how
we do business that there's a court case
or court cases pending uh for example
last term you know we have somebody in
death row and the legislature
you know passed a death penalty statute
so i think it's important to point out
the legislative process should not stop
because this court case is pending
thank you very much representative
further questions
thank you
uh
just uh back to the discussion uh
earlier about uh
our article six of the constitution
of new hampshire
what's referred to as the compelled
reason
clause
i'd say that
we are not compelling someone to support
religious
school we are
supporting with the town's wishing
program
the students
of that town who do not have a grade
level
to attend
they have to be sent according to state
law
to a school
for
their education
we are complying with that
um
provision of state law
uh the school board
has clearly stated in the uh
glitch in the bill that you're
discussing
uh states that the school board will
just
decide on
what schools to contract with
and so i
we are not
compelling
uh support of any
particular religious school to the
exclusion of other schools
so i
don't see that that argument
plays
in relation to this legislation
and
again
if we leave language
uh in
with uh
not passing this bill
that court case will proceed
because it is clearly unconstitutional
based on the espionage case and you'll
just be inviting additional court cases
uh maybe someone in goshen will next
file a suit
um so uh you know if you want to uh open
it up to more uh
court cases uh fine but we can uh comply
with the uh supreme court ruling in the
espinosa case
and um
make this religiously neutral in our
statutes
okay thank you very much uh further
discussion
clerk would you please uh come over on
this amendment please
okay this is amendment
zero six one six h and the
motion is spot to ask
representative pordelli yes
president paul yes representative
ballard yes representative
yes or senator moffitt yes
yes representative andres yes
representative
yes
yes representative saudi yes
ben miller
no
representative shaw yes representative
cornell nope
representative tanner no
representative ellison
is no
mullen no
president way
no
president would cop no
representative lad yes
uh
12 80. thank you very much uh represent
cordelia if you have a motion
thank you mr chair i would like to move
uh ought to pass with amendment
for house bill 282.
i would second that
mr chairman thank you thank you very
much
um
thank you it was fine sir
okay uh we have a motion to afford uh
this uh this bill
to
pass it uh
since 282
with the hot pass with amendment
further discussion from the maker of the
motion
from the second
no
for the discussion
yes representative paul yes
representative allard yes representative
yes from zen moffett yes president
yes
representative andres yes
senator ford
yes
yes representative saudi yes
representative
no
representative will know no
senator shaw yes representative cornell
no
representative tanner no
senator ellison
no president
no
representative
nope
new
transcendent lad yes
uh uh we will have yes there'll be a
report and then and represent tanner
will do that report
on the sheet that i fill out it asks
uh
what motion
the minority report
uh will will or what position the
minority report will take
about itl i assume it's ideal
it's trash and the same and the same
with cacr3 too
i i assumed it but i just you know i
thought i should let you know that
unless you unless you have a different
one other than itl you can let me know
as we go on
if there's a minor report that's
different from ipl
very good
thank you very much and while we're
talking reports here i i
i apologize i haven't opened up my email
for you know since probably about four
o'clock yesterday or three o'clock
yesterday afternoon
uh
i i like to ask those folks that are
owing if you haven't if you have uh sent
your uh uh committee reports and other
bills
i thank you for doing that if you
haven't i really need to get those
things in as that
the folks uh upstairs are trying to get
their work done and and of course
they're going after me to get that stuff
in so and i i recognize you're all very
very busy but please try to get those
completed thank you i sent mine last
night okay so i understand that i
apologize
last night because i don't know
horseback today
um
okay uh going on down to the next goal i
see here uh below that and i have 136
that's the records that we have
non-binary students
and i'm looking for representative
howard to make a motion
what number feel like
136.
yes mr chairman uh i would make a motion
that uh house bill 136
the itl
thank you representative
second second so we have a motion on the
floor for as that is ipl for
hb 136 and it's been made by
representative howard and seconded by
representative
representative do you have anything to
say on that
uh
not at this time mr chairman hey thank
you representative
yes thank you miss chairman yes we
during the hearing we realized that this
bill does require money
from the state and there's no financial
note deadlines for
second bills has passed so the only
thing really
you need to
i
tell you further discussion
rexella
thank you representative
ladd
there's been much discussion on this
bill and on the amendment
which is basically the same except
allows parents into the discussion
and the money issue came up before and
we heard the money issue from the
the uh department
uh that they regularly they regularly
update their programs every single year
we heard the money issue that there
wouldn't be a 28a
because the local school systems who
have contracts are in the contract if
it's a law we've heard that the smaller
school systems already using it already
made workarounds so it's not really a
money issue at all
what it is is a
parent choice issue to allow students to
be recognized allow students to be
uh receive less bullying to have more
self-confidence and to allow school
staff and faculty to be able to identify
and work with these youngsters
just today
just this morning we heard again
from a representative who's sitting in
the lob we got to think about parent
choice and from another representative
the lob we heard it's time to get out of
the 20th century and get into the 21st
century this was just 10 minutes ago
so you can't have it both ways this is a
very simple bill that allows parents to
make the decision on their children uh
on on what they want to declare and
particularly those youngsters who are
non-binary and that that is a pretty
simple change in the in the uh
legislative process so i would urge you
to
decide to stop speaking out of both
sides of your mouth and take a stand one
way the other to stick with those things
and vote i 136 and allow parents to help
kids to get in school to be recognized
the correct way that they are
thank you
representative
uh thank you mr chair to follow up from
representative woodcock you know we
talked just talked a minute ago about
not discriminating from a religious
standpoint
now we're talking about not allowing
parents to represent their student
i mean where is the consistency here
as you begin to look at the issue of
discrimination
thank you
um thank you mr chair
uh
you know this bill is
is an easy build to put into effect
but
on the other hand not putting in into
effect is very dangerous
we know that transgender students
are probably the biggest target for
bullying
uh harassment
suicide attempts
as well as
um you know just just being teased i
mean being discriminated against
excluded
you name it
and by making this one small change
which we have already done on
driver's licenses
to make their lives and their parents
lives
just a little bit easier
so that they can go to school
and they can go into a classroom where a
new teacher is teaching
and looks at the roster
and
makes the proper pronoun
i mean it's as silly it's as easy as
that that's that's what we're asking to
do in this bill
to make
lives of kids
and
parents
less complicated
less dangerous
and and to make the schools
non-discriminatory
this i can't believe
how we're having bills this year that
are what i call mean-spirited
because these people are doing nothing
wrong
they just want to be recognized
for who
they are
and i would urge
people that have the least bit of
conscience
to vote against this itl
thank you
thank you representative
yes i totally agree with the previous
speakers
as a former teacher
um i i know what it's like because even
back when i was teaching there were kids
that were
transgender or different
than
it was difficult
and and if you accidentally called that
person a girl or a boy
there was a sense of
um you know
embarrassment for the child and yourself
i think that it is
it is just a matter of a couple of
columns
on a computer they update their their
records constantly
at it at the state level at the city
level there's always something new that
has to be added this is not
a major
issue
it's a simple thing they did it like
representative jackson you get it at the
stake
for the driver's licenses
there's no reason why it can't be done
in the school
and it it
it is a matter of morality it's a matter
of
um
not
singling out
um students
it's inclusiveness it's all the things
that we
support and education
and and i
i cannot understand why
we can't support something like this
anything
that helps kids to maintain their
self-esteem and and and their self-worth
and i
believe in this 100
and and uh i will be voting definitely
against the idea
represent thank you mr chair um
after just listening to the
representative from manchester i was
wondering if we could uh have a brief
recess
uh a recess to caucus
[Laughter]
that's good
cover both faces
okay there's been a request for uh to
recess for a caucus
uh
seven months we will do that right now
no what do you want to do
it's 10 19
according to the
my
computer
okay uh
how much time do you expect you're going
to request to rip some off about 10
minutes
thank you
yeah well let's let's let's take it's
easier because if they want to caucus
they're going to have to do it the
remote way and all that so about uh
10 minutes we'll come back
at 10 30. back here 10 30. okay
and we and we will we will caucus
remotely i'll send i'll send the link
out right now
thank you thank you
okay
wow
there we go
okay we are now can you hear me out
there
yes thank you represent
uh i i'd like to recognize uh
represent howard
uh thank you mr chairman
based on our consultations over the last
few minutes uh i would like to withdraw
my itl motion
representative yes i agree you sent me
all my okay so
the motion for itl has been withdrawn
representative moffatt
thank you sir i'd like to make a motion
to uh to retain this measure
and i'd like to second it oh yeah
uh yes i i just want to refer back to
the representative from manchester's
comments which i uh i took to heart and
uh there are a lot of points i think
that we need to discuss further there's
a financial component
uh and
there are some other comments that uh
perhaps should be made as well as we
move forward
okay representation uh thank you very
much uh i would like to point to some of
the other discussions that we've had uh
we would have the issue if we only
change the record of the sex or gender
to represent the way that the student
wants to be identified because we may
have a menstruating student who
identifies as male and if this is a
single notation in that column you might
have a substitute that doesn't
understand why john needs to go to the
nurse's office because john's claiming
that he has this period we have larger
issues to look to here and i want to
make sure that we are respecting that
individuality of students
we need to understand exactly how this
would be done in the software and make
sure that there's consistency so that so
that it doesn't become even more
confusing and i believe that between
that and looking to any cost of either
adding a line or how to have some
standardized procedures in order to
reflect these student preferences i
think would better honor their
individual individual identities and
help reduce potentially embarrassing
confusion
represent woodcock do you have your hand
up yeah thank you
president ladd a couple quick things
just to clarify for representative leon
um
typically when students ask to go to the
nurse's office you say yes uh rarely do
you say no just because of the legal
implications and also the fact that the
student has to go to the nurse's office
um so that's that's not a consideration
i don't think the uh
people who teach know that uh in the
software the software product uh
costs you know we've already gone over
that i talked about that before the
state does it every single year when
they update the grades and when we heard
the education department speak at the
hearing they said that a normal piece is
they would have to send out training and
do if there was any complications so it
would all be unified so that and many
schools already do that and i want to go
back to quickly the the part that that
we talked about initially this is the
second time we've had this bill in in
two years uh and it's all the same it's
a student interest bill it's parents
trying to help kids every time if you
have school kids in public school every
time you go to register youngster and
particularly when you change buildings
um it's a it's a aggravation and hassle
for the parents to get their youngsters
set up the way they're supposed to be
unless they have a very understanding
school system
and then when the youngster goes to
class it gets the wrong name the wrong
pronoun and all the stats that we've
just talked about and heard about the
negative impact on youngsters i mean in
my amendment uh which doesn't come up in
the retain obviously talks about
allowing parent choice in there uh to
add into that piece we've and i don't
understand how you can keep on pushing
like the board pushes parent choice and
anti-bullying and anti-discrimination
and then keep on voting back this
there's nothing more simple than this
allowing the school to put the correct
name on the correct list so a youngster
did not get embarrassed the youngsters
did not get uh their further their
psyche uh feeling really bad about
themselves and get more and more
negatives i mean look at the number of
kids in public school that cut for a
host of reasons
and have all kinds of
ideations this this just plays right
into it all we're doing is creating more
damage more danger for kids
thank you
thank you representative ford
thank you mr chair uh
i spent a good deal of yesterday talking
with my uh constituents as well as with
medical people i have contacts with and
they're pretty unanimous on this this
issue is bigger than just the child
being embarrassed the issue is one of
possible crucial diagnosis should a
child show up doubled over
and difficult to diagnose what's wrong
with them if they don't know what the
the birth biology of the child is from
the start
and they need to have that unambiguous
both pieces of information
the issue does arise in some schools
where it's difficult to get find a place
to put that
but i kept thinking my gosh if you had
an old apple 2e you could put that
information on that for the nurse to
access but that's my own simplistic
solution
the idea is that that's a problem that
just needs to be worked out and we need
to work out how to put it in a bill like
this but the the reality is according to
the people who have to deal with this is
they need both pieces of information and
they need it immediately as soon as the
child presents themselves with possibly
uh
being you know seriously ill
appendicitis comes to mind things like
that or if someone has a bad
period in terms of pain and pressure and
bleeding and all or if just some other
complication
miscarriage is there they need to know
right then what they're confronting not
minutes later after you've looked it up
in a file somewhere
that's my point thank you representative
represent tanner
thank you um and i appreciate the fact
that my colleagues
on the education committee
are starting to think
uh and and ask themselves the questions
about about this bill and bills like
this about transgender students
retaining this bill is just as bad as i
telling it in my my opinion
um in my 35 years teaching
unfortunately we had
i think six different students take
their lives suicide
for various reasons not obviously not
all of them or transgender or maybe any
of them
but
to have a young person take their own
life
is
affects not only the family the school
the community
it's a terrible terrible thing to to go
through
if
one
we save one student
now
by passing this bill rather than
retaining it
it's worth the 20 000 or whatever
that people put in in as a stop gap on
why we can't pass this bill
this bill
will make the difference
a tremendous difference
in the lives of a few students we're not
talking about a lot of students we're
talking about a few students
and let me tell you that as working hand
in hand with school nurses
they know who's transgender and who's
not
they know
who's
because they're looking out for them
just like a lot of the other teachers
are looking out for them because they
are targets
and
they um
it isn't a it isn't a medical problem
within a school
i can assure you that
that the school personnel know exactly
what's going on
this is for the kids
this is for their parents
this is for people who come into the
school as substitutes or maybe work in
the cafeteria
today's kids don't have names like
mary jane and johnny jo
they they have names like maybe green
and
it's it's gender neutral right from the
beginning or or like my dog raven you
know who knows right
um
this would be something that like i said
would make
a tremendous difference retaining it is
just going to push it down the road
give us another
year
where students are miserable are bullied
people are cruel to them
for no particular reason other than
they're trying to be who they think they
are okay that's all it is
and it they don't hurt anybody else
they don't hurt the classroom
you know this is such a mean-spirited
uh
bill to itl or retain i mean it's it's
just the bill is not mean-spirited the
the fact of retaining it or itlling it
is
that i just i implore you
to take away the retain
put in a ought to pass and let's get
this bill and get this change on the
road thank you
leon uh thank you mr chair uh
representative tanner i'm not sure if
you recall but when we were talking
about the private rate of action we were
concerned about transgender children who
have died because of bullying issues so
we do take transgender issues seriously
here in this committee on both sides of
the aisle
i do appreciate that there are many
students who feel comfortable sharing
with the school nurse that they do have
a different biology than their express
gender identity however as this becomes
more prevalent there are students that
are transferring from school to school
there may be
someone who presents as a young man who
has transferred into school and now is
identified by his by his preferred
gender
and presents in pain
suffering from a ruptured ectopic
pregnancy and if he does not have that
established relationship with that
school nurse that school nurse may not
be looking for a ruptured ectopic
pregnancy and we could be looking at the
death of a transgender child because
we haven't reflected the full
identity of that child both their
biology and their preference and that
could cost that child or life if we're
talking about if it saves just one child
we don't want to put in a solution that
serves us today when children are
transitioning in their current schools
and ignores those who have moved into a
school district or have
changed grade levels into a new building
and nobody knows them as their
biological gender they only know them as
their their gender profits
and this could put lives at risk we need
to look at this as more than just one
line we need to look at this as
biological gender and also look at that
expressed interest right now there are
schools that we've heard are putting
this in the notes line that helps but
perhaps what we need is one where we can
identify birth gender and express gender
and then that can respect if that can
respect children all along the spectrum
and make sure that we don't lose a
child to a ruptured
pregnancy or some other
gender-based biologically based health
issue that needs immediate
identification i understand it's pushing
you one more year we have the notes
column and but as you said if it could
save one life it's critical
thank you very much uh represent uh like
yes i was going to say many of the same
things that representative land
said
um
so i think
i guess
i'm not sure the bill as written will do
what you want it to do
i think you need to look at a better way
to write it
to maintain not only the
biological gender for health reasons
and put in the
preferred
gender
because a legal name is going to be very
important at the hospital or various
other places they're going to need that
legal name for health insurance and
various other things and so
having a place where
a note that the parent will include that
says this is what
my child prefers to be called
this is um what pronouns my child
prefers i think there needs to be more
than than what is in this i think we
need to expand this i think it's a great
idea we need to expand it
and if we have that notes line
that can go for not just transgender
children that can go for special needs
children we can have those notes that a
sub
or somebody else needs to know
about a child so that they don't
embarrass the child
or themselves
by referring to the child a different
way because don't forget we don't just
have trans
we have non-binary and so
how are you going to put in one in a
column
how a non-binary student wants to be
referred to so i think we need to expand
this
so that we can still keep the legal name
the biological sex
for health and safety reasons as well as
the preferred name the preferred gender
the preferred pronouns
and any other things that a sub
or a
medical doctor or whoever is going to be
interacting with that child
that the parent wants them to know about
that that will help them with
interacting and respecting that child
thank you rexella mullen
thank you mr chair for recognizing me
uh as many of you know i'm a school
counselor by profession so i've lived
this
um i i think that
allowing a parent to choose non-binary
and i want to draw back the attention to
the fact that this bill came to life as
a result of a request
by constituents parents of transgendered
and or non-binary children who asked for
the opportunity to reflect what they
feel is accuracy and honesty in
identifying their the gender identity of
their child uh we're still talking about
children if they need medical care go to
a hospital or have to
produce a name or whatever for uh
insurance purposes there's they're going
to require a parent to do that anyhow
so
i look forward to the day where if uh
medical people or an administrator or a
teacher looks at a student record that
has non-binary checked off that they
immediately think outside the box and
think about whether or not they have to
make
adjustments in
medical assessment or care
and i look forward to the day when a
parent doesn't feel that they have to be
dishonest in their own mind about the
gender of their child
and i look forward to the day when we're
not asking parents of non-binary or
transgendered children to provide
information on their ch on their
children that we're not asking for on
everybody thank you
representative shaw
yes thank you uh representative mullen
would you agree with me
that
this bill
is just a legislative uh directive
which allows
uh the third column or whatever you want
to call it
and that the student records
are probably much more detailed and they
probably do include a lot of this now
records are confidential
and they can't be released to everyone
so by just seeing
that there is a
um
an additional
uh
column if you want to call it or
whatever
uh for that child then the records can
be divulged into
so that
uh you know but by making more of this
bill
this bill as it stands right now gives
the
open door or the policy or whatever to
the districts to go forward
uh with
what they're probably already doing
in silence and doesn't show up
uh in in ordinary so that
it's obvious there's more to this and
they need to develop into the records i
don't know maybe
i'm not looking at it right but i think
this bill as it stands
is perfect should just move forward
and then all the rest of this is local
control it's local
schools it's individual schools it's
parents and individual schools
it's
not just a one size fits all a week you
know we can write a bill that's 14 pages
long and it's still not going to cover
everything
this is like a basic
let's move forward
so that
x y and z can be done
i would agree with you uh representative
shaw that there are authorized users in
schools that have access to student
records that do not allow for
just anyone in a school building to
access
confidential information and i also
agree with you that this is a clerical
piece of information
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you mr chairman i would just like
to point out that um i think maybe
there's been some
misinterpretation of the
legislation um in terms of
sex and gender
but the bill specifically requires
recording of a student's sex or gender
there are not two different fields
involved this is requiring one field
to designate
your vendor
so i i think that
you know
you are wants to have two designations
uh you're looking at a different piece
of legislation
um other than this amended bill
brooks out of tanner
thank you i i just want to i know we're
talking about
kind of about risk management too
um and when you talk about etopic pros
pregnancies it happens in about two
percent of total pregnancies
uh and death occurring from those is is
very small
um if they're you know they're taken
care of
on the other hand transgender students
have
something like a 41 percent
suicide attempt rate
uh
and
that's that's an enormous difference
uh
in risk management
and as we've mentioned before
you know uh in order to get medical
attention medical care and the the files
that the school nurse has or the school
doctor that does the the sports
physicals
in those particular documents
they have to be done by the parent
and i'm sure that those those documents
document what what the student is
undergoing
particularly in transition because
there's probably hormones involved as
well
or maybe in treatment and
i think that's
an issue that that
is already taken care of this this is
just this this has been done by the
department of motor vehicles
um so that people don't get harassed
when they get stopped
that's that's all this is this is to
help students their parents
students who are particularly at risk
high risk thank you thank you represent
like us
yeah i'm looking at this having
while i have taught i knew my students
when i taught
but i subbed for three years as well and
i subbed in a variety of different
schools
and
as a sub i did try to get to know a lot
of the kids that i saw but i often came
across kids that i didn't
and um doing something more than just
in the same column
putting a x or whatever then i have to
embarrass the child
by saying
i you know
what what do you want to become what you
what what
whatever and that child may be shy
and i know as a child i was very shy and
to have to yet go once again
through the fact that i wanted to be a
different pronoun or whatever
would have been extremely embarrassing
to me to be called in front of the whole
school and it would be much easier if um
this was expanded
anyway i see you shaking your head bro
tanner so i will just be quiet
uh i'm going to allow
represent woodcock to speak we've uh
some of you taking two three four times
to speak here um representative woodcock
do you have something further to say
yeah yes thank you first off and i
apologize my entire computer internet
went out because
uh apparently my uh plug wasn't it and i
missed all of representative cordelli's
uh speech i'm sure all the people who
took care of whatever it was and i
apologized glenn because they didn't
hear what you said um that being said uh
all due respect to representative lakers
nobody stands in the front of the room
and say they don't know what to call you
i mean if you see something in your
student teacher notes that says
something about a youngster you make
down well sure you figure it out to talk
or something you never i mean you're
never embarrassing anyone like that
that'd be the worst thing you could
possibly do
and and most schools have orientations
for a team orientation for youngsters um
and that may have been already covered
that that come in so i just want to
clarify that point and once again say
this this is something as representative
shaw said is very simple and it can say
and it can save a huge amount of
discrimination and bullying and negative
influence on youngsters but these kids
are adolescents we know this this is the
worst time in their life everyone's a
bully in that school and we talk about
eliminating bullying folks that's not
happening and but we can make sure we
can give one step forward to make it
easier for parents and easier for
youngsters um that's all you gotta do is
just
hold off and retain
pass the bill and allow families and
youngsters to to help and be respected
in schools and be safe you'll be saving
someone
thank you and i apologize for losing you
representative cordelia
thank you very much
uh sean would you please call them that
yes this is to retain her house bill
136 representative cordelli
yes
representative holm yes representative
power yes representative
yes presenter
yes
representative
uh hanson i'm sorry yes representative
andres yes representative ford
yes
representative leon yes representative
soti yes representative miler
no
representative
representative shawn no
representative cornell no
representative tanner
oh to save lives
representative
a non-discriminatory no
yes
hb409
relative to filing certain vacancies
among members of school boards
and other school district officers
thank you thank you mr chairman i would
like to move on pass on house bill 409
let's say a second
second representative
so now we have a motion before s on four
zero nine
i'd like to speak to that represent
ellie thank you
[Music]
um
if i uh
go back to the testimony that we had on
this bill
is that it reflects
and mirrors what's in statute currently
uh four towns
uh i did follow up with deputy
secretary scanlon yesterday just to
review
his testimony and ask
there is no confusion among clerks
currently
um
and then
this legislation and the talent
legislation establishes a clean
cut off
uh a brilliant uh
demarcation
and that um
he said importantly i think that it
prevents
uh scenarios where someone could play
politics
with um
an incumbent could wait until
um
half an hour before the deadline to file
um withdrawal and have his friends
standing beside him uh register when no
one else was able to
register for uh that ballard position
so i think that there is a safeguard
against uh trained politics
through this legislation
simply uh i had questions during the
hearing that have since been answered uh
by
dave scanlan and others so uh i i agree
i concur with uh representative cordelli
all right is there further discussion on
this bill from members of the committee
yes representative paul yes
representative allard yes representative
yes
representative moffitt yes
representative
yes representative andres yes
representative ford
yes
yes representative saudi yes
representative miller yes
president
no
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
rip said tanner yes vincent ellison
yes
representative
yes your friend
no
representative
we lose you again representative
woodcock
the latter is staying still an awful way
yes
we'll just hang loose a little bit here
for him
while we're waiting mr chair could i ask
a question
hey
guys
i'm i'm back mr chair damn computer i
apologize that's all right yes or no
yes ought to pass thank you
okay
18-2
thank you ralph 18-2
but i have a question of rep cordelli
when it was conversation with the
secretary assistant secretary of state
do they have examples of this actually
happening or is it just something
they're afraid will happen of somebody
experience
a half an hour
we are done with that bill right now
okay all right sorry
it was just a question it i already
voted i i i think you can give uh person
a call explain that to you
okay
yeah is there any objects putting this
on consent no
well will there be a minority report
no
thank you
so we have one one bill left for today
on the dock america's
does anybody have to take a break right
now for about five minutes
okay we're all good so 182.
yes
thank you mr chair i would like to move
off the pass on house bill 282.
182. i'm sorry
oh sorry the two of them were so similar
yes i would like to move out to pass on
on house bill 182 and i would like to
to move the amendment sorry what is that
number mr chairman zero six nine zero
zero six nine zero each is there a
second from uh for uh
yes i am mr chair even though you might
think contrary given that little mix-up
[Laughter]
um i
i'm speaking in favor of this bill
because um the amendment i guess to the
amendment first the amendment specifies
the language so that all students are
granted the same ability to transfer
coursework that we that we offer to
students and military families this
provides consistency and consistency in
the education where even if you're
moving from district to district or
otherwise changing your education you
can you can be sure that you are moving
towards a path to complete your
education
thank you very much
representative
no i don't i don't have anything to add
further discussions
thank you thank you representative just
a couple quick things so this this would
take uh if i is this correct now this
would this would take away
the principal's current prerogative of
accepting coursework
locally
with the clarification representative
leon
if i
i believe actually can i refer that to
the author of the amendment or
it's a question this question you
brought the amendment is asking does
that does this now take away the
standard practice of the pres the
principal the local school local school
high school particularly making the
decision
um it standardizes it to what's
happening with the military and they're
there this is something uh
as i understand it standardize it with
the military compact from the question
is it's a local principle now the
authority they lose it
and pulling up that village
uh the principal or the administrator of
the high school that's receiving this
credit uh has the option
with accordance with that amendment to
say no we're not going to do that
it does require that principle or that
administrator to provide reasonable
justification for that denial
so it does say that the principles may
and can deny it it includes that in that
same sentence
well
rather than lay for a lad follow-up
please if i'm looking at the amendment
at line
uh five and six or six particularly it
says shall grant credit it doesn't say
may it says shout
so that that that's not an option
and it says four shall provide
reasonable justification for denial
at the
but the sentence question i may i'm
going to raise my may representative lad
is just
we're all still aware that the now the
school board association said it's not
necessary the secondary safe association
says not necessary and the public input
was eight in favor 96 against i mean
this is really not a necessary bill it's
not it's not military families at all
military families are already under a
compact
as it has nothing to do with military
families we throw that in there as
alignment
thank you
i'd like to respond that i just received
a
letter
from an individual and i'm going to read
part of it
uh it's an example i know a student
transferred from new york that person
took algebra in eighth grade it meant
all the standards and requirements but
since it was not taking a grade nine the
school refused to grant credit despite
the fact that she was in her senior year
and have already been accepted to
college at the time the decision was
rendered
that's the issue we're trying to resolve
that when it comes in from another
school
and it's
and
the principal has the option then to
look to see if the standards were met if
it reflected what they asked for
and their school then
it should be accepted represent i saw
your hand up i just find that that
that's that this argument you're making
here this is an unconfirmed letter we
haven't heard from the person we don't
know whether this story is true or not
we don't even know what the details are
we don't know why the district rejected
it uh there may be other reasons we
don't make state law based upon a single
story unconfirmed with no detail from a
single individual
i mean that this is it's ludicrous what
you're proposing here to do
the fact of the matter is we saw no
evidence that this is a problem right
now there was no testimony virtually no
testimony that there was a problem and
when we asked about velax or anything
else there was no testimony that this is
an issue right now so you are trying to
solve something that is there is not
evidence that there is a problem thank
you
cornell
thank you mr chair i
velex had come up in the original
discussion so i did check with velax and
they said they actually have very few if
any problems with their classes being
accepted um the only time it might be is
when they want it to be accepted as a
course for for that's required for
graduation and the school said no that
is an elective
and they understand that it was an
elective that the this
family was trying to get um
called
a credit course and so i checked with
caitlyn davis at the department of
education if they hear
that velax is
not being accepted at schools and she
said
she could not recollect any except in
the same case that a parent here or
there would call to say
that the school is not accepting
something as a
required credit toward graduation when
it was an elective course so velax
themselves that they have a wonderful
relationship with almost every single
public school in the state and have no
problem especially when they check with
the school first and say we're going to
take this for vlax for credit and then
it's no problem whatsoever so velax
isn't
relax and the department of education
both said this is not a problem
thank you mr chair i have spoken with
several parents that have had a problem
with transferring credits and having
courses accepted
even more i've heard from many many
parents who are very concerned that the
credit may not be accepted at a later
date this is something that's stifling
education choices right now and is
leading parents to be afraid of doing
anything other than following the
prescribed path even if that isn't the
one that best suits the student's
education so this is something that may
not be may not have a large impact for
all students but it is keeping some
students from from having the coursework
that they want the one that will benefit
them and will drive them towards their
college education and as we did here i
have heard similar testimony as chairman
lad about um about having these these
late rejections that are impacting
students college acceptance and this
this is critical to their education
representative uh
thank you mr chairman i think we need to
treat
all students the same whether or not
they come from a military or from
another state or from another district
if the course is accepted because
from a military compact then it should
also be accepted if they come from
another state
and so
that's all i want saying that thank you
thank you representative
i contacted our superintendent of
schools in the merrimack valley school
district
about v-lacs being accredited and his
reply was
assuming the online courses are taken
via an accredited institution like velax
and the enrollment in such courses has
been collaboratively planned through a
student's schedule process
credits are granted towards graduation
thank you for taking my question mr
chairman thank you represent cornell
uh thank you mr chairman
i will just mention that
i attended the elac graduation ceremony
year before last
fantastic
event you should all try and attend one
but i did talk to the director
um at that time and he confirmed that
there were districts uh not accepting uh
velax uh credits uh and i also talked
with a former state representative whose
husband um if uh
the uh chair of the board of trustees um
and uh they confirmed the same thing i
do not recall if i asked what schools in
particular uh but i just wanted to make
the committee aware of that
thank you um i
voiced this
concern when we first went over the bill
and i'll voice it again
um
reasonable justification
is a term that's in this bill
and that the principal has to come up
with
um and i'm sure that there's going to be
some sort of process built up to appeal
this
um and it's such a big term to begin
with what it what's considered
reasonable who who is the person who
actually makes the
the decision that it's reasonable if the
parents don't think it's reasonable is
it reasonable
um and i'm thinking that that probably
is going to go to the department of
education and i think
that we need to know
um
more about that particular part of the
little part of this bill i i realize
it's it's two words in this bill but i
think it makes a world of difference
um in what the principal has to go
through
what kinds of things maybe they need to
uh
base their reasonable justification on
if if they have required courses that
are specific to a school district
and that course can only be taken at the
school district because it is
specific to that district
can they refuse somebody from using
an elective course as a as a substitute
for that that that seems to be
one of the big issues if if you have to
take new hampshire history and you live
in new hampshire that's you know that's
going to be part of your school district
course but if you're coming in from new
york
maybe you don't make meet that
requirement
um so i i think
there's a real issue with that and um
plus the issue that as
representative woodcock said it starts
out with
the principal shall accept credit um i
think
that's the principal makes the decision
thank you
i'd like to just uh add a few more words
here that
within the
military contact it starts out the
purpose of this legislation is to remove
barriers to educational success imposed
on children and families because of
moving or job assignments etc of their
parents
and we know that occurs frequently
within the military
however we also know that our our
society today
beyond the military is very global
and we have others that are moving about
this country as well and throughout the
world
and so it's
i cannot understand why
if we can have it set up in law like
this
for the military but it just won't work
for anybody else it seems to me that
by doing it this way we are
discriminating against a certain
population
based on we're allowing it for one but
not the other
representative
uh chair may i have a follow up on my
question on on your statement
mr chair
um i'm wondering
if the if the department of defense
education
um schools
uh have a policy that they have to
accept
any credit coming in to them
from a student who may be already
started at another at a civilian school
and then transfers into one of the
dod schools
because they're they have pretty high
standards
can you answer that
um i i
thank you mr chairman i i can only
answer it in terms of my own experience
that's fine uh with uh
and then i would say yes because my
my son bounced back and forth between
eod schools and
civilian schools in
seven states i believe
uh and
never had any problem transferring in
credits to dod schools
thank you and and all 50 states have
signed on board with this contact
so that's why it's it's throughout
[Music]
okay you're not seeing any further uh
discussion here i'm gonna call ask the
this is on amendment
zero six nine zero h ought to pass
representative cordelli
yes
representative bone yes representative
alice yeah
representative
yes
representative moffat yes representative
thompson yes
representative
yes
president ford
president leon yes representative sodie
yes
from senator miller
no
president of luna no
representative shaw
um
i lost my train of thought um
no
representative cornell
no president tanner no
representative ellison
oh
do you have a motion um yes mr chair i
move on to pass as amended on house bill
182. thank you represent hops
thank you very much
uh is there a further discussion on this
oh i'm sorry i just didn't take it down
okay thank you
not seeing any further discussion i'm
going to have to call the role please
yes this is about to pass as amended
on health bill 182
representative cordelli yes
representative phone yes representative
allard yes representative
yes representative
yes representative thompson yes
representative andres yes
no
yes
representative tanner will be issuing
the minority report
thank you
all right so in recent land you the
majority report thank you
those are the uh five bills i believe we
had scheduled for today
um
any further comments from the committee
other than that it's time for lunch
are we coming back after that or are we
done
no those are five for today and that
leaves for tuesday next
um i'll go through the bills which we
have uh the four remaining bills
uh 255 that's the limited liability
business uh bill we have
university right
then we have 202 that's the school lunch
program
and 203 uh the commission study of the
school lunch program
and then we come down to 388 manifest
education hardship
those i believe are the four remaining
bills we have
so i i i feel that uh
uh and remember when we meet next
tuesday we'll be starting at 10 30 due
to the fact that the senate head is
starting at nine
and it was very difficult i know for
those wanting to testify to be gone and
run an exact at that time so we're
starting at 10 30.
with those four bills i would expect we
would be out
relatively you know
shortly thereafter uh on that on that
tuesday hopefully by by one o'clock two
o'clock that day
okay so not seeing any i i wish
everybody have a great weekend and for
those that are on the subcommittee
dealing with higher edge see you
tomorrow
thank you